williams seconded
and i'll get
rid of that off the screen sorry who
seconded
i will robbie now
councillor blackie
i'll put it all those in favor raise
your hand say hi
carried anybody against no
any matters arising from the minutes
councillor williams
um yes i just i don't know the staff
there to answer it um
i asked the matter about staffing to get
all these some of these drainage issues
sorted um for this covered uh whether
they need other i just like to know
whether the staffing shortages for the
contractors are still as there's still a
lot of drains that actually haven't been
cleaned um properly and winter is just
about upon us
um how they're going
keeping enough staff to um or contracts
to do this or should we start looking at
some local
um different contractors to help um
because there's nothing worse than a
drain not being cleaned out on time and
um
you know we have flooding issues because
of do we need to bring an extra contract
because that's a question because i i
can see that the drains haven't been
cleaned yet after standards
so i don't know whether
who's there to answer that question that
unfortunately
no well i can see this mr cleary's
joined us so i'll pass over to mr cleary
uh look apologies for being a minute or
so late for the start of the meeting um
yes look i uh i can answer that
generally um that question and then
perhaps kelly might be able to add
some specific detail and details in
relation to the drainage um
maintenance but there is generally
pressure across the whole industry uh in
terms of both capital works and
maintenance
contractors and
so um that is something where we're
finding a challenge and that's
across all of our operations so uh you
know from everything from refuse to um
road maintenance the lot now contractors
have been um really good at managing
that on the whole but it's fair to say
there's not not a lot of if any spare
capacity and we're finding the same with
the capital works um
with uh we actually do
our drainage maintenance contract is
as you'll be aware through cycom but
they actually do subcontract to a local
contractor michael stockforth
and they've actually brought on extra
resources themselves from
what i understand it's but they do have
challenges from time to time and just as
an example they might have all the
operators they want but they need a it's
it's really hard to find a truck driver
so look um that's being managed and we
do always have the ability to bring in
the extra contractors if we want so if
the service isn't being delivered
then um then and
that's not happening then we definitely
will we're happy for you to
um to you know talk to me directly about
specific drains that you've got concerns
about the uh behind um and talk to happy
to take that off
line uh kelly did you want to take add
anything to that
uh just the only other point to add
there is that we are actively working
with
cord to look at prioritizing which
drains they're working on at the moment
um
so to make sure it's the key ones that
are being maintained and getting
addressed
um but yeah like jared said if there is
specific drains of concerns um we'll
make sure that they are on that priority
list as well
my question was if cord
can't and stock was can't actually get
enough staff and contractors on it
should we start looking and we've
already been told all the existing
contractors we use now are pretty much
stressed out and full maximized so we
start using some of the smaller
contractors which are local ones that
have got some ability to do some of this
to get some of those drains cleaned
before winter and our water season comes
that's that's was the question should we
be doing that because obviously all the
contacts were used now are stressed and
fully
well they can't get around do it all
should we be using some of our other
smaller local contracts to
get them cleaned
um ready for the winter before we have
some floods
um so i'll just answer that uh we can do
that and we can either do that by
requesting our main contract to bring on
more resource as subcontractors or
ultimately if we're not happy or really
what uh uh do need action we can engage
some ourselves
whether we should do that or not
at this point we are having those
conversations with our contractor um and
if we're not satisfied then that's a
step that we've got up our sleeve to do
councillor stuart
uh yes thank you um i raised the um
the item about
the
website listing
of all the um
flood issues that the new team is
addressing at the february meeting
um oh march meeting um i couldn't find
it on the website i note that we i still
can't find it i note that it's um item
5.1 we address it again i still cannot
find
on the website
where you go to find these updates can
someone assist here
mr clary
i can answer that one
so the link is actually in the report
or sorry 4.1
um
sorry 5.1
uh
however the um the link in there
the there had been some delays with
updating the website with the latest
information so that's probably where the
confusion is coming in
um but that would be updated in the next
few days
so
further question
how are people who want to click in the
60 or up to 600 that may want to know
where things are at
how they're going to find it there is
nothing on the home page
so we are working with the comms team
regarding that and they will make it
easier to navigate
um to that specific link
um
including having links from a more front
page as well
well can you be
time frame and
be really specific about it because i
expect to be able to go to the home page
scroll down and instead of finding a
reference to library services rangiora
airfield or enc
this to me
a link to the work that the council is
doing
addressing all these flooding issues
should be there
that that would be in place in the next
couple of days
definitely by close to play thursday
all right thank you
i haven't had an indication of any
further question well matters arising uh
i have no deputations or presentations
so i'll move on to reports
five point
one uh thank you mr cheers so the
purpose of this report
is a follow-on update from the previous
flood report that was presented to the
last
uh unr committee meeting
so the flood team is now well progressed
with um a majority of the investigations
um
table one
in the report on page
shows that we're
uh
underway or have completed
26 of the 59 investigations
so the two that are complete
uh put a place which was um the cleaning
of dudley drain from a hockey road down
through to the railway line
that is now complete
and also queen street in oxford so the
finlays drain section so we have been
through there
and cleaned out um three different areas
of the drain through there
uh 24 investigations are underway in of
the remaining investigations
the majority of those um 28 of them have
been assigned and there's only a
handful of investigations that are yet
to be assigned to anyone in the flood
team
you will note that here uh
there's updates on um
the five key focus areas so this is this
areas these are areas where
um
there was either reported repeated
flooding or a flooding um
of garages
uh
that we are
we've elevated because of the severity
of the flooding in these locations
so broadway air
in waikoku beach
we have completed a design there and
just looking at confirming that design
based on some recently completed survey
work
and we anticipate that we will be able
to go back to the property owner there
in the very near future so that
would be sometime over the next week
once we've actually um
confirmed that concept design the
next steps from there were to get their
feedback on that and then um
look at
whether that work is um how whether we
can fund that from existing budgets or
whether that would be a staff submission
to the drafting plan
swindles road in my cookie beach um
you'll see in the report there we're
looking at a range of different options
there
um
and uh it's a combination of short-term
medium-term measures right through to
long-term measures we're expecting that
that will um won't be able to be funded
from existing budgets and will be a
submission to the draft daniel plan
fuller street in quiet point we've had a
meeting with the
landowner there
um
they are one of two properties whose
land wasn't raised up following the
earthquake
and they're prone to flooding from the
drain to the north of their property
along the railway line
we've got some further investigation
work that we need to undertake on those
two properties
but we
have a potential
solution here
installing flat gates um to effectively
try and prevent any
uh overland flow back from the drain
into that property
uh
cast road
there's actually three discrete areas
that we are
looking at in cust
the
probably the more critical one
is at around about 13 oh sorry 1838 1840
cass road um where there was um
significant um flooding
near a garage
uh there's no
positive drainage identified in that
area
and the soap pit that was recently
installed is not working adequately
so we're currently investigating uh
potential options there to um resolve
that localized issue
the other two sites within cust where it
is more to do with
um
cctv inspecting of pipes maintaining
drains making sure the system existing
system is operating as efficiently as it
can
so two things there in terms of
off-site investigations
we
have put a camera through a 300 pipe
downstream of ranui news it's a pipe
that goes from ahoka road
along vicari street to the panam lane
pump station
and
the lower section of that pipe we found
some significant fat deposits
um
they were quite large to the extent that
they were restricting the capacity of a
300 pipe
down to something equivalent to a 150
pipe
so
that fat has now been removed from the
system
which would have significantly
increased the um
performance of the off-site system
on-site we are still continuing to
work with the property team to
investigate the
um potential venting issue
and we've got a plan in place to
undertake some further work
between
through some of cameras
private laterals from the individual
units
and also to do a simulation to try and
replicate the um
uh issues that were experienced with the
toilets on fire the reason that we're
still
following up on that while we have found
an issue off-site
we
have done some further work to find out
that even
even though uh ranui muse was
experiencing issues with their toilets
none of the
uh stream properties or downstream
properties immediately adjacent to
ranoim use experience the shoes with any
of their toilets during the event
so while we had offside issues
we still believe that um
the toilets at ranui news should still
should have been operating uh adequately
even with those off-site issues
occurring
uh so that worked there it will be
undertaken in the next couple of weeks
um
finally the other thing just to let you
know is that we've packaged up some of
the survey and cctv
work
um from multiple packages uh multiple
projects into one package in order to
undertake the work
more efficiently
so that's just to give you an
oversight of where we've got to i'm
happy to take any questions
so i'm not sure whether it's the mirror
or a deputy me but i'll sit there hand
over there
thank you mr chair
um
just around around here
news
where would the fat deposits come from
on that line and if that's
down or off site and down stream so to
speak
what relevance will that actually have
if the places downstream aren't having
the backup problem what relevance tool
does it have to run their inverted views
so the um
about a year ago we had some issues with
excessive fat deposits
into the platinum lane pump station
and as a result of that
we actually needed to go and undertake
some
uh
cleaning of the wet well at parnum lane
pump station uh what we didn't actually
realize at the time is that the uh off
level for the parname lane pump station
actually caused that 300 flow to go back
up the 300 pipe so we actually believe
the source of the flat fat deposits
um occurred about a year ago when that
issue occurred
and it was into the parnum lane pump
station
yet there was um some
flow or fat push back up the line
that wasn't cleaned up at the time
so we believe it is a one-off
um
occurrence
so that's the first part of your
question the second part of your
question is
um why why is why is that important
um well we've actually gone through and
had a closer look at what's the effect
of the fat in that light and it it does
actually cause surcharge in the pipe up
along a hookah road so it would actually
push the
levels in the sewer line
higher
um
up
excuse me
in the vicinity of ranui news
which would um make
the renui
is more prone to having issues with
their toilets so
that's why we'll look why we're looking
at that
just just to clarify then
so did we find the source of the fat
deposit or didn't we just do we know
where that came from 12 months ago for a
push back up there did we do what have
we done about that uh yes we did um it
was related to one of our trade waste
agreements
and um at the time they had an issue
with their on-site system and they made
us aware of it immediately
and um
so yeah it was a no-one one-off issue
thank you
that's williams
yes um
on that page um
what is it 17 you've got all the green
underways
um how many of those are actually
physically starting or is it just
paperwork um and planning
did you get that kelly
uh yes
so um
these are all underway meaning that we
have
actually physically been out to site
undertaken um
an assessment and we've um got to the
point of um
you know having a clear scope that we
need to work through so but they are
um
you'll see that there's four in the um
table there
that are
not yet started
so they are ones that you know are more
in the category of the desktop
assessment so the ones that are underway
are ones where we've physically been out
to fight we've actually got contractors
out um
doing work and people um who have
submitted those service requests should
have actually seen um or heard from
people physically doing the work
so you're probably going to um know what
my next question is have we got enough
have the contractors we've asked got
enough time to do all that before our
winter strike because to me there's seem
to be quite a lot of work there and not
enough contract is what we employ can
they do that job before the
the big
reigns start coming
that's the important question
um
yeah it is a very good question and that
was one of the reasons that we've
packaged up the cctv work um
you know to make it a bigger package of
work that they can get their teeth into
um maintenance work is probably
it's probably actually more
um
being managing a lot of smaller little
projects with our existing maintenance
contractors so making sure that um
making sure drones have been inspected
um so that is
part of the flood teamwork is to make
sure that has um been
undertaken at this point in time when
not finding um any
um significant issues with uh getting
contractors
it's actually at this point in time the
um
the flood team itself like you know
working through all of these service
requests
mr cleary you want to comment
um yeah i just want to add there will so
um
there will be a number of these where
there might be some immediate works that
we can do and so um where we can do that
and if obvious physical maintenance
works
um that's fine there will also be some
where we might be able to do some
immediate work but there's actually some
longer term issues and
they might require quite substantial
capital upgrades um and they and some of
those will come to the annual plan um
and some will come to future long term
plans or be subject to future
investigations so
um just i think that might help answer
part of your question councillor
williams in terms of we're not going to
fix all of these problems to the full
extent before winter some may actually
be
level of service uh expectations that
can't be met or can't be met without
quite substantial capital works and
upgrades
and some of those might need to be out
into the future just as an example we've
if you think back to 2014 we had quite
substantial flooding
then um
we
again carried out a whole pile of
immediate work
we've been
continuing with the capital works
program and probably the biggest of
those is the um kayak or shovel ready
projects that are happening now um
so
you know
so just i don't want you to have the
impression that we can fix all of these
problems before winter some of them are
long-standing um
issues that you know that are that go
back decades um and some can be fixed
more immediately but there's certainly
what um will be some that take longer to
get around to the the question was
mainly asked um regards of whether the
maintenance like for example and just
before winter i'm not likely to hop into
my car and go and find for example a
shopping trolley jammed under a bridge
blocking a a drain and all that type of
thing because we haven't done the
maintenance on it it was amazing
maintenance on their existing drains
will they be sorted before
our rainy period starts coming
that was the question really
well i i guess at the end of the day uh
councillor williams our staff are going
to do the very very very best that they
can
to to ensure that
we don't have these mishaps
so i i realized that but but it was just
as um aimed at the
contractors have we got enough to do
or what our staff need to be done to
clean the drains and that was what jared
was saying before
if we haven't we need to bring in some
extra contractors and we don't we
shouldn't be bringing those contractors
in after it starts raining the drains
need to be cleared before that before
the floods arrive all right so i i'm
pretty sure you've made your your point
both at the conclusion of the minutes
and with regard to this report and i'm
sure that our staff will be taking those
comments on board mr mayor or deputy
mayor you still got your hand up was
there something else from you guys
yes there is
councillor mailings thank you thank you
mr chair i would say i agree entirely
with councillor williams's question
and i would like to to know
that those items that are immediate
issues are being resolved and can be
resolved and so
jared and kelly i think we need some
regular reporting to us to make sure
that those capacity issues are under
control
with those maintenance issues that have
been addressed it's been raised by
elected members here many times now
so i i do support us getting more
information on that so maybe a weekly
update to us to keep us under up-to-date
with what's occurring what be
appreciated uh waikoku i'd like to know
have we connected with the residents
down there following uh our meeting
during we had earlier in the year we
gave some undertakings i've read the
report i'm just not sure if there's been
communication that's gone back
uh to those residents that raised those
issues
uh in renewing news is something i view
as a top priority
and i'd like to to
keep if you can in that weekly update
please make sure that we're kept up to
speed with what's going on i don't want
there to be issues that run you use
like what we had last time around it's
these are our pictures they deserve the
best service from us and um i just want
to make sure that we're keeping on top
of that please
all right so obviously it'd be a good
discussion to have in the management
team as well wouldn't it
counsellor mailings
thank you mr chair um just on page 17 on
your table
of um focus areas um just regarding the
hoka rural uh the three properties that
you've listed there i'm pleased to see
that you're underway with two of the
three but of the one that you haven't
yet started on mill road
i know that they were contacted after
the flooding event and i'm grateful for
that
but has that resident been contacted
recently are they aware of the status of
the investigation with regard to their
property because the um stream did get a
little bit closer than we would like to
see
and um yeah or does is this particular
property one of those ones that falls
into the category that jared just
just discussed that it's
a bit bigger and wider and possibly
bigger scope than we can deal with right
now
whereabouts is is 175 at this moment
uh
so
that one
uh
dan lewis has made direct contact with
the landowner there and um
has already been to site
um there has been some initial advice
provided there and i understand
subsequent meetings uh
uh
been planned
thank you so so the resident is up to
date then with with the status of their
um request great
great thank you you're a deputy me you
still got your hand up this is what yes
because i didn't get enough with respect
mr chair i have raised these issues that
management team i'd just like to have an
answer to the points that i made please
thank you
um look here the uh issues um you've
used you're quite right uh
those um issues have been raised by
the mayor um the deputy mayor
um a number of counsellors um
so
um there are effectively to the your
three questions the answer is yes um so
i
agree we should be giving a more we're
happy to give a more regular update on
progress um
specifically
on these issues um and i think perhaps
that will help
with
keeping you informed if there are i
suppose if there are any
individual grains or individual concerns
that counselors have
please let us know um
you know
let either me know or
kelly know and we can make sure that
they are followed up um but and uh but
you're very we're very happy and i think
it is appropriate given the time of the
year that we're now in that we should be
giving you um
a weekly update uh on on issues
so uh because you're quite right we're
heading right into winter
right i can't see any more indications
of questions so we've got some
recommendations somebody prepared to
move
moved councillor redmond
no are you another question there was a
question yes i i'm not permitted to move
at your uh meeting mr chair
um
just the the questions that have been
raised um
do the existing contractors um
well let's put it this way are they
meeting their obligations under the
contract in terms of levels of service
especially in relation to maintenance
look i think it's fair to say that
um there is a backlog at the moment and
that the
um
water operations team and drainage team
are working really closely with
the contractor to prior to prioritize
the work and to make sure
um that we are getting on top of that
backlog as quickly as possible coming up
to winter
um
they have looked at
how they can um reorder their own
workforce um and the their
subcontractors
as well as getting an external help to
get them back on top of
the um the work as well
i think in terms of the
um
levels of service so that is something
that
as part of the ongoing meetings that we
have with them you know where we're
um always reviewing and rating their
performance to make sure um you know
we're getting the
best value from from that maintenance
contract
i i think it's just always challenging
when we
have um
these kinds of seasons where we do have
a lot of rainfall and we do have a
relatively warm summer
um
having excessive weed growth um having
issues with
drains that sometimes
uh only needed to be cleaned once a year
some of them were having to clean three
times every year so
it is making it a bit more challenging
um
and
i think from this we're just
making our own internal processes as
well as chords processors
um improving them such that we're
providing a um
a better level of service for our
customers
thank you
if they're not meeting their contractual
levels of service
what are the financial implications
uh so a lot of the there's some of the
drains that they may maintain they thus
i'd a
yearly
rate so irrespective of how many times
they maintain them um
they that's
we pay a set amount each year
then there's other drains that we pay
for on a time and expense basis
so if um
if it's a
wetter warmer year then we'll end up
paying more for maintenance of those
drains
um we don't have any penalty payments
within the contract when they
um they
get behind non-certain drains
they're just then put onto a list that
we then say to them look you know this
this is the dream that has um
needs to be maintained and then we track
the list to make sure
that it's getting off that list as soon
as possible
thank you
councillor williams
yes um
i'm quite a wee bit i'm worried about
sometimes when you said drains they'd be
clean two or three times instead of once
because i understand if they weed rate
them and don't actually take the roots
of the reeds and they the actual salt
away from the bottom of the drains
properly
it's only a couple of months and the
weeds grows bit quicker are they
actually cleaning are we going out and
checking to make sure they are cleaning
the drains properly into a proper
satisfactory situation um because it's
only natural i've got to be pond here if
you weed rake the weed out the top of it
or grow really quick because of the
weather conditions so you've actually
got to dig out the roots and the bottom
of the drains to clear them properly
which um
it's just wondering whether we're
actually checking to make sure that
work's been done properly
uh yes and we'll also be um inputting to
the method that they do use to undertake
the maintenance of the drain so you know
we'll work with them to make sure that
the method of cleaning is the most
appropriate
right so as i mentioned we've got the
report with the recommendations somebody
prepared to move move council williams
second and council blackie councillor
williams
yes no so we've been concerning this um
report because um
i just personally i like to see us on
top of it and obviously we're not quite
on top of the um cleaning and everything
yet and um i think
if we can't get on top we need to bring
in some more exterior contractors to do
it but i think we need to get on with it
because there's nothing worse than water
and we can't control water and if the
drains look dirty
the right parts come to come back to us
and say hey my drain's not cleaned
that's why my house is getting near
flooded
and um if the drains are cleaned well
they can't come back to us and say that
so i think it's very important
thank you that's the black council of
lucky no nothing to add
just me up
i thank you um just
can i say thank you to the staff for
this report but it's it's helpful to
have this here but that more regular
reporting thank you jared and kelly for
agreeing to do that but we when we're
fronted residents there's a number of us
have over those events these issues are
actually really important to them and to
know that there's a process in place for
that there's a heightened expectation
because of the number of weather events
we're going and that's putting a lot of
pressure on our staff and our resources
so it's just to keep for from my point
of view i think it's really important
that we keep a picture on this and uh
are kept informed and if there is
additional resource um required
personally i'm more than happy to
support that because
when you're fronting residents at the
time of a weather event uh you know and
a number of us went and visited those
last time around that's are pretty
concerned uh and are rightly concerned
about things we've got work programs
coming uh significant stormwater
project in kaiapoi which is going to
resolve a great deal of these issues
but we we keep experiencing this
unseasonal weather which then puts the
pressure on as i mentioned the issues in
my cookie that's been a number of years
now
we need to
make sure
what we're looking at is communicated
effectively with the residents so that
it addresses their issues ranui news
we've already mentioned that there is a
concern and i do want personally want to
see that result it's a top priority
and um
the other measures that we've raised
through cast last time round that has
been logged now and hopefully
you know these are things that need to
be programmed and worked but a number of
these issues have popped up a number of
times so we just need to make sure we're
on top of it but
and this reporting does certainly help
us but that more regular reporting will
reassure us
that that work is occurring so just to
acknowledge the team i know there's a
lot of work going on but we also need to
be making sure
that we are kept informed because the
heightened expectation that there is in
the community then comes back to us to
be able to answer those
questions at various times it's our job
to make sure we're satisfied that that's
under control thickness chair
council stuart
thank you i just want to endorse some of
the um comments um i'm in touch with
several of the um
um
residents on the on the
further investigations list and
while i note that um the report says
that they've been contacted
they've told me they haven't so um i'm
really concerned that a communications
um really steps up here and that we as
councillors are kept across it and
thoroughly endorse um
a weekly update i think the worst thing
is that um
you get it in the air from residents
told told something from the staff and
they don't match
so i think it's really important
not only that the council is also across
it but
as i said earlier
the
website that is meant to be informing
everybody of um what is happening is
really easy to get um access to
it isn't
um and i would just
we have to do better
on
communications of whatever we are doing
it needs to be regularly updated and
very very easy to access
because
as councillor williams has said we're
heading into um winter and if we've got
a whole list of things which we have got
a whole list of things still to address
and i've i've had
yesterday
anzac had another issue i didn't know
anything about um but i've passed that
on to um to kelly this morning and um
i i hope that in fact it's one of the
one of the um flooding issues that
was easily resolved
at the time it doesn't seem to have
been communicated back to
the property that was affected if that's
the case i just
reinforced the need for absolutely
well very very good communications
thank you
i can't see anybody else so go back to
council williams write a reply
no no reply so i'll put it all those in
favor raise your hand say hi
those against
it's carried
thank you for that
so i have no uh correspondence
so we'll move on to item seven which is
uh reports
uh 7.1
thank you for that and i'll speak to
this since we no longer have kathy here
this is uh
the effectively the there's a bit of a
passing lane at the tram road early's
road intersection and there have been
some issues with
large vehicles parking there on blocking
visibility so we're looking to formalize
that as a with a no stopping restriction
any questions
somebody prepared to move
you got a question wendy
um just the question please with where
you
where you've got that bit of excess way
for a for a truck to park which is
blocking of course blocking the way but
where else can can
the truckies park their trailers
when they're perhaps going off to get
some other stock
um
yeah and and uh we haven't identified
specifically freight locations i think
looking at a freight strategy is
something we have
sort of pegged as a
near-term effort
but
that location specifically has a traffic
safety impact because it does block
visibility whereas there are a number of
other locations so again we haven't
specifically catalogued them and
identified them to truckees to pull off
um recognize there is a need for further
coordination on that and that is
something we have picked yeah thank you
because that is a real issue that they
do not have a place to park over
thank you
for williams
my question was pretty much the same as
the same council of duties was
those trucks are parking there for a
reason
um if they've got nowhere else to park
are they going to park in a place where
there's not so much width and create a
bigger problem further on down tram road
that's a wee bit of concern
if you you know do you know why they're
parking there
uh i
based on the comments you received it
was not
targeted at a specific company or
specific truck so i cannot speak to
exactly where they are coming from or
going to um yeah
council of duty
yeah
they they're parking there because they
they've got a
a double carriage
and the filled up one was stock and
they're going to get another load and
then couple them together and off they
go but that's what that's the only
reason why they've done that is because
rather than taking a truck in a trailer
as well that they can just put one aside
and go pick up another lot that is the
reason why and that's probably why you
do need to have a little talk to the
truckies about that and that area thanks
so we've got a recommendation somebody
prepared to move
i'll move it from the chair somebody
prepared a second
second in councilman williams
it's self-explanatory i've got nothing
further to add
council williams
yeah no i've got not really much to add
apart from
exactly what um council of duty said
that they will park their trucks
somewhere else and i just hope they
don't park it in a
uh a worse spot um for the traffic
that's that's my big concern so i don't
know how many other places there are to
park there so i'd hate to be moving
something here now and finding out we're
making a worse problem somewhere else
down the road
can't see any other members no reply
i'll put it all those in favor please
say aye
against it's carried
7.2
um and i'll take the report as read i'll
just add since this was passed on to the
community board uh 17th of march we sent
out an information notice discussing the
potential no stopping change to
the owners of the five properties
affected and have had no feedback from
that point the original design didn't
include a kermit channel on the west
side which is one of the big constraints
however that's
sort of the result that came out of the
the consent process with the developers
my understanding goes
and so that is that is the circumstance
we have out there on
vaughn street which leads to a narrow
carriageway and a struggle for providing
space for parking
mr clear you want to rate something
uh yes i do oh just to add to um what uh
shane has talked about there are a
number of physical constraints on this
site so
if you look at the photo in
page 49
that shows you the where the vans sort
of parked up on the
curb there's a large hedge there
that actually goes out uh quite a long
way into the road reserve
that hedge is a shelter belt for the
council reserve
um and
we
effectively from a
reserve point of view need to have that
shelter belt there so we've had
discussions with
the staff
from our community and recreation team
um
potentially there could be a longer term
option
there to perhaps duplicate that hedge
before bringing it down but that would
be a very long term issue there's only a
small number of properties along here
and
there's really and you need we need the
curb and channel for drainage purposes
um because if there hadn't been carbon
channel there possibly it would have
been easier to people to pull over a bit
um but the developer required that for
the providing drainage and we wanted to
get a good drainage outcome on the
subdivision it's this subdivision has
got some significant drainage challenges
um and there was quite a lot of
backwards and forwards all the way
through the consent process on us
uh between the developers engineers and
our engineers to try and find a
compromise that worked the best
look we think the best type that the
owners of those properties remembering
that they're either under construction
now
or haven't yet
been finished
are being have been advised
of that
and none of them have come back
which was the strategy that was endorsed
by the community board in terms of the
consultation method
um it's one of these things we don't
want to leave until
residents move in and then we're
changing the environment for them um
and you know they might form a habit of
starting to drive on the park on the
road so it's just trying to get ahead of
the game
here um so that hopefully that'll answer
some of the questions that might have
been coming on this
council williams
yeah i think that sort of answered my
question i was just making sure that all
the property owners have been consulted
on because that was a question
that come back from the i believe from
the uh community board and at that stage
that people hadn't been consulted on
that was also they definitely have been
consulted on there is they correct
everyone
my understanding is that um
there are there was i believe perhaps
maybe one house potentially occupied the
rest are all either under construction
or have not started so we have we did by
post um notice to consult on it to one
resident there and the other four owners
who are
in other locations
so
council ribbon
uh thank you mr chair um i think i was
the one who raised at the board um that
the owners had not been consulted at
that stage so that was why the
recommendation the last
uh
part of it is as it is so i'm pleased
that um
they have now been consulted and it
appears there are no issues
um my question is um given the width of
the grass boom
if that had been narrower there would
have been room for on-street parking
so do we know why the road is quite
narrow and
the boom quite wide
when it would have been maybe preferable
to have around the other way
look i'm happy to answer that
um the
boom is not particularly
wide
we do need to have berms
for a number of reasons
one of the things that's not good to
have roads up very close to boundaries
so particularly when people put up high
sided fences
the other thing is services go in the
burn
and what you're seeing there is not us
the trees go well out into the road
reserved so
um ultimately
the um
you know that was one of the constraints
that trade was tried to be resolved was
to try and um achieve
an outcome that allowed for a burn uh
future proof that so ultimately if the
hedge issue is resolved and that
it needs to be resolved in the future if
it needs to um
then it'll be manageable without any
parking on that road it's actually quite
adequate to service that
area um but it's just it's not
uh um
so those were considered joanne i see
you've got your hand up um you might
want to add something to that
yeah i see it too thanks julian
um yeah and um
just to add to what jared has stated uh
there's a stormwater large stormwater
pipe which runs along underneath
uh the boom area which needed the
additional cover um so the the road
couldn't because of the depth to protect
the pipe couldn't be directly over top
of the storm water pipe
um and the outlet level was constrained
so that was one of the factors that
needed to be considered into the design
thank you i'm happy thank you
okay so we've got a recommendation
somebody prepared to move
uh mr mia or deputy mia one of the other
yes i'm happy to move all right and
seconded councillor stewart well
actually i'm i'm sorry i'm a bit um slow
but it was i've got a question here um
which i'd like to ask well i asked the
question
yeah well by the time i got my reaction
my hand up
you'd moved on to moving it
question
thank you
seftontown is
split with its rating
environment canterbury does the rating
for everything except
rodent
road drainage
and i'm si and the when joanne brought
up the fact that there's a
a pipe underneath that'll be stormwater
pipe that is rated for by environment
canterbury
um i'm just raising the question here um
is this split of responsibilities when
in fact you've got development occurring
in sefton
with no
town centre plan or town growth plan
that i'm aware of
the way to go
mr cleary
that is a really good question
and it's certainly something and it is i
have certainly turned my mind to um
the
uh i can answer it and it's not a good
it's not you know
i will answer it it's it's a it's a it's
it's a real challenge um sefton has
its existing
stormwater system is pretty much
non-existent um
it's just it's a series of road culverts
um
vehicle crossings that have been put in
over the years with undersized pipes um
uh there's no drainage rating area in
sefton
um and it's one of these areas there is
a tiny little story
not as we know them normally
yeah so certainly not a by mackerel
district council urban drainage um
system
so it is one that potentially if there's
further development this is going to
continue to be more and more of an issue
um and it'll come down to
drainage levels of service in terms of
uh pedestrian access
uh so there are there's actually um
quite a challenge for the community of
stefton in the future um and at the
moment and so when it's been sort of a
semi-rural town that level of service
has been acceptable um this is a new
development and i did point out there
was some quite significant drainage
challenges on this site um it's on
an area that we do have a fairly steep
gradient um you get quite an orographic
effect and then when there's an easterly
um air uh movement and
weather where where there is often quite
a lot of water dumped upstream of sefton
and that's hence why there is that
environment canterbury rating area
because there is an issue for major
storm events
um particularly on the uh western side
of sifton um but look
that is certainly such a future
challenge for the council
whether we want to and that may be
something we talk to the committee about
go out and consult with the residents
and do they want to um trying to get the
council involved more have maybe
something slightly slightly more formal
possibly a waimakariri district
rating area for the area
and then that would
ultimately lead to a series of capital
works uh over the years but it's it
would be
it's it would be quite challenging
trying to retrofit urban stormwater
services into what was that a town given
the way it was
developed in the past so i i genuinely
thought that was a really good question
because it's certainly something we've
been turning our minds
to right so it was moved mr mia oh sorry
you had a question council award or your
second name oh well i'd have a wee
question um you've just raised um
over the weekend it was raised with me
by a real uh by resident of safety and
that with the new subdivision
and some growth in sefton
what is plan for footpaths for access
particularly for the school children to
the certain school
mr cleary or mr binder
oh
um
joanne mcbride will not join
yeah again a good question um
sefton isn't currently rated for
footpaths it's a little bit like uh
the stormwater management areas and the
general
look and feel and sefton for
facilities is
more of a settlement area that doesn't
have paths so we wouldn't be looking to
install foot cars within sifton area
it was just raised the fact that the
children are walking on the road to go
to school so that was raised with me
actually yesterday so um
i thought it was very
relevant to ask the question at this
time
all right are there
before i go back to them here are there
any more questions are going to pop up
no mr mayor you moved somebody second
and second and councilor williams mr
mayor
uh just briefly to say i support the
recommendation
it's an issue that perhaps the time of
subdivision and consent it was a matter
of perhaps
it should have been picked up on it's
now one that does need to be resolved
because it has left a situation there is
where we are it's been to the community
board and has been recommended by the
board
uh the concerns were um uh raised with
me by other elected members and i just
want to say that i
i did pace it and pass it on to mr
cleary and i appreciate jared you
and
shane providing and enjoying those
additional answers here today the fact
that the residents have been
communicated but if they hadn't have
been probably would have been looking
for a slightly different recommendation
because i think it's really important
when we have effects that occur that we
do communicate effectively with our
residents to make sure that they are
notified and aware of what the
consequences are but look at to i think
it makes sense this uh this direction
and so i'm supportive of it thank you
councillor williams
council
stuart yes thank you um
i'm quite
relatively comfortable to support this
but i do
raise the question um i'll raise the
comment following my question that
this council is ticking off development
in sefton
there are three
rating areas for drainage that
environment canterbury
manage or administer uh sefton town
which has got a probably a budget of
something like
fifteen hundred dollars i mean it's it's
absolutely minimal um then there's the
wider theft and ashley area and then
there's the ashley
area proper
we are ticking off development here and
and
this is an example of a small
development um which has got
considerable challenges as have been
outlined here
and there are more to come here for
sefton um i just think it should be on
the list
of um
a briefing
we have no there's no town centre plan
for it it's um it's a popular area
for some people to
uh to move to and it has serious serious
drainage issues
um
so i mean
i don't know what the process is i'm not
going to um
add a um an amendment or anything here
but be warned um
councillors and staff we need to turn
our attention to this township it does
have has no services it has
major resource issues
and um we are ticking off development in
it
so
that's um i would like i don't know what
the process is um
to
get a uh
a more comprehensive look at the growth
of this town
thank you
thank you i can't see anybody else mr
mean only reply
uh just just briefly to say that um
we have signaled already our intention
to look into drainage right across the
district so that's next turn we've
discussed that a couple of times this
turn of council and that's our agreed
position i think what counts the duties
just raised in the chat is something
quite relevant which is a perhaps a
township plan or a discussion with the
town at some particular point but that
should be part of that holistic
work that's being
considered i wouldn't want to see it
done piecemeal
and and we are looking at
the broader issues there and safety with
the community
facility as well which we've committed
resource to so it's part of the growth
of of um sefton years ago we did um
work within both ohaka cast and
which ended up with plans so i think
that's a it's a very good suggestion i
account sir there are really good
exercises that we went through and that
identified the sort of things like
council awards
talking about around footpaths in a
hiker we ended up with footpaths
extended
for the school students so i think the
growth
that's coming there is and it's clearly
desirable for people that want to move
there this is part of the growth of that
we do need to consider that so
a consideration of a plan and then those
wider servicing issues would be very
helpful to have and we should start to
get a work program together to
identify those and discuss what that
might be particularly having that
conversation very openly with the
community about what they would like to
see
thank you i'll put it all those in favor
raise your hand
say i
anybody against
that's carried thank you so we're going
to item eight so we've got some
matters for information 8.1 8.2 and 8.3
if somebody prepared to move all three
of those
was that your hand castle award
yep move council award seconded
i'll second from the chair
i'd like to talk about some of these
things first we can
you've got questions
yes
yeah questions the request report for
decision yeah we where we got to the um
the screw bridge run yet
well we were going to move all three
council williams but if you've got
questions
council award council award and i will
hold off
yeah i've got questions yes i have
um
on the sku bridge one um
would it not be sensible
just to spend the money on the
electronic signage
first and to see
um
whether that souls are roughly a bit of
a problem because it's the the cheapest
part of it and that's probably the main
part of um doing that contract
so
we can always if we needed to do the
others afterwards but surely
um we don't need to spend
the rate parts are struggling now with
money it's just just seemed to me like
we're throwing money after money after
things like this when the important
thing is to reasonably slow the cars
down and that signage is going to be
quite adequate in my books to do so
joanne
yeah um good question paul it was
something that we've been through as
part of the design process for the
bridge
and
as part of that design we've put in a
place a number of measures or
we have taken to unr
which has previously been approved a
plan which included a number of measures
to support lower speeds
through those air through the area and
across the bridge
our recommendation is the signs would
not be adequate on their own and that
has been through a say independent
safety audit
process and supported the work that
we've put forward
so
um can you explain to me why just the
signs wouldn't be adequate enough um
because i'm quite lost about it and um i
would have thought we would have been
told about that in the briefing why
signs alone weren't enough when i
personally was being at the meetings and
i thought the signs were pretty much
going to be at the basic the major part
of it and the maybe we were titivating
but didn't realize that the signs was
probably the cheapest part of the whole
program
so as part of slowing um traffic down it
often takes a combination of factors
to help get the slowing of speed so
what we had
in the design that went to unr and was
approved included
some more of a threshold treatment and
changes to the road markings so that
included some curbs around the signs
we need a little bit of pavement
widening at the signs to make sure we
can accommodate them safely behind the
edge line so they will be protected
and even the road marking through there
putting in the wide center line helps
narrow the lanes and that in itself is
helps what helps achieve the reduction
in speed so
just doing the signs alone in our
opinion is not not enough to get the
speed reduction that we're looking for
i haven't probably got a problem with
just white lines and a bit of painting
on the roads but
you know another 130 odd thousand
dollars is
getting up there that was all i was
thinking
any further questions
council duty
um just the question on this one um
what is what is more valuable
the the
health of a person that may have had
accident there
are their life or is it the um just
saving money on on doing extra work just
make it safeguard
yeah well
i think i think it's a bit of a more of
a point making
no i did ask the question
well i
no we're not the point that the point's
been made and uh we're not going that
way any other questions
so
counselor
paul you still got your hand up
thank you very much
um so council award you're prepared to
move before you're still the same
absolutely i support anything that
makes it clear
old second okay
oh dear
okay can i speak now yes yes please yeah
thank you so i support um i'm really
worried about the scuba bridge and i
support anything that will lower the
speeds and and the awareness of people
to slow down and keep their keep on the
right side of the road to avoid any um
any
accidents happening
and i can tell you um it's not very
pretty we had an accident last night at
it at our home when a man went to sleep
and
and came and
and belted into a vehicle at our home
which was parked up our drive so it's so
easy to have bad drivers in accidents
and i think anything we can do to slow
them down and to make
make things safer is what we need to do
thank you i've got nothing to add
anybody else
no
i'll put out all those in favor please
say i
knows against
that's carried we go on to portfolio
updates
councillor williams
now you meet me you're muted paul
i shall start again
um yeah it's really good to see the
staff finally um working on upgrading
the maintenance on our levels of our
gravel roads around the district myself
and andrew wells have been worked hard
to see this happen as the feedback we
were receiving from the rape piles on
the gravel road suggested the roads
needed to be upgraded and it's really
good to encouraging to see the staff
actually starting to listen and
i understand it's all happening so
that's that's a really good thing to
come up
i am although disappointed with the land
transport on their funding systems
that's not helping councils keep their
roads maintained to the level that's
required especially when i see the level
of what i believe is such a waste
of the ltsa money
on um
for example
3.4 million dollars on
some of this advertising which i find is
very similar to the um
the three waters um advertising
um the level of the maintenance around
roads and what have you
isn't up the stage and i agree 100 with
what the
automobile association is putting out
about the um the roads and everything so
i'm very disappointed with the level of
funding we're
receiving from government on
um doing air road maintenance and what
have you
we've got an update fernside pavement's
rehabilitation work is now completed and
the road is
reopened
the pavement rehabilitation site at
wrangler wood in between gulf links and
smart road has been delayed until next
season due to temperature dropping
and staff shortages due to covered
some holding work has been carried out
in the interim
the chip ceiling program has been
completed for the year
footpath renewals are underway on east
belt
curb and channel renewals are currently
underway on dharam street and
also on a short section of east belt
above whale street
a reporter's coming to the council on
may on the february flood event and the
options for the butcher's road
um pipe culvert which has failed and
grading and mettling of the roads
is coming
on the culvert on watchers road
i don't know jared maybe answer that
we're going to get a bit of a briefing
on it soon
i'm very very disappointed that
um
i believe such a reasonable small item
um it's taking so long to get resolved
and we've got a road closed it's like
we're in a third world country and even
a suitable country would have that road
open by now so um
i'm hoping we'll get a good briefing on
it and um find some way of even
temporary getting that road
opening and that's all for now unless
jared wants to comment on that culvert
um you said do uh we have a report
coming to the council um
on that so
the uh council meeting there's a
comprehensive report on the drainage uh
sorry the roading um issues uh
particularly associated with the number
of service requests we've had in the
weather um and that has a
covers the
culvert in there so um we're happy to
i think we'll give that report to
councillors as part of the agenda and
we'll be happy to take any
questions on that if councillors want to
get hold of either me or joanne
prior to the meeting to discuss that
report we're really happy to have
those one-on-one conversations otherwise
we can take any questions at the council
meeting as well
thank you award did you have a quick
question he said just a quick question
in your research paul with your team
um did you um for the maintenance that
were you looking at the conditions of
carlton road rights road and doncaster
roads
um
pretty much we went covered try to cover
as many roads as we could and we um
just pretty much basically um most of
the roads of
lacking a bit of um
top dressing and what have you and some
of them got the big cluster boulder
sticking through it so
it's really
um i don't think he's a councillors we
actually should be going down um
full-time inspecting all the roads all
the time but it was necessary for myself
and andrew and we did um some roads and
i also went out with councillor duty
around the oxford roads inspecting some
which is good um but i think it's the
staff needs to get on top of
some of the areas and yes all of all the
gravel roads pretty much from why my
career needs a bit of attention
i'll send an email to you jared and um
with um some concerns of truck drivers
that have been speaking to me
councillor mailings
i'm yes thank you mr chair um paul thank
you for uh mentioning the butcher's road
i have gotten quite a lot of feedback on
that and i do share your frustration
that um our roads aren't able to get
fixed as quickly as we would like them
to be however i would just like to pass
on a bouquet to joanne mcbride
i had a constituent reach out to me and
ask if
it was possible for it to be made at
least
available for pedestrian footprint foot
traffic and cycles
and
not only did she entertain the thought
but she made it happen
and so at least
those who are riding bikes and and
walking through there can actually get
over that culvert now and i just really
want to thank you joanne for going the
extra mile speaking with the resident
and going out looking at it and making
that happen
because whilst it's not our road fixed
we do miss the road um people can still
use it in a limited capacity which is
capable right now you know which is
possible right now so thank you for that
i just wanted to say in front of my
colleagues that you were amazing so
cheers
yeah and i did get feedback on that um
walkway a cycleway as well
some of the local residents here are
quite upset that they thought we've
spent more money trying to get a cycle
way up and going there than what it
would have been to temporary fix the
whole culvert system on a temporary
basis to get cars and their own cars and
saving some petrol and everything
from going around so
okay
yeah so so no no no no
we're gonna move on we're gonna to move
we're going to move on to 9.2 councillor
stuart
thank you um
very little to report apart from the um
working through the list of
flood-related
remedies that we had as part of this
agenda
um and and as i said having more come to
light um which i've communicated um
through to kelly uh just to understand
where some of that is at um
my um hearings panel on the stock water
review by law still waiting to see um
the communications package that is
coming from that i would like to
have that accelerated um
it um we it was very clear from the
hearing
that
many um people on the stock water race
order race system um did not understand
um their obligations uh and and the
opportunities that they have so um and
this was last year i tend to remind
people that we had these hearings i
think it was no november
so yeah so it's getting on for um
six months since the hearing and i
haven't seen a draft of the
communications package so looking
forward to that apart from that um all
good thank you thank you councillor
stuart
so we're going to utilities council
williams hey again
um
i haven't got much to report on this at
the moment um
the sewer side of it the the botulinum
at the um the waste plant down at um
cracky beach has been less than what
we've had in previous years so
that's actually
you know looking quite good we've had a
few deaths of birds but nowhere near
like we've had before so
and the weather's been warmer so that's
quite encouraging
um with the water supplies the only
concern i personally have on it is
we temporarily chlorinated some of the
coyotes water when we had a wee bit of
um
thoughts of a problem in it it wasn't a
problem as it turned out but the
chlorine and the water does affect some
of the pipes and i've i have got a
concern
whether if we're forced to chlorinate
the whole of waimakariri um you know
kyboy and mangura supplies we actually
might
run into bigger problems with um
discoloration and um residue in the
pipes that may get affected by the
chlorine but apart from that that's me
for today thank you
thank you
so we'll go on to me with waste
so there's been a minor issue at
sutherland's pit kitty's working on the
possibility of putting some camera
surveillance
in there just to make sure that the
people who do offload
actually offload what is supposed to go
in there and not something else
um waste management um
as you're probably aware uh they've been
sold to an australian owner an ingenio
investment um we've been told we
shouldn't see any significant changes
the chief executive
was at our uh zoom joint landfill
committee meeting
which was held on the 4th of april
and on that meeting on the 4th of april
with regard to
cape valley
we
accepted the interim report from
transwaste
we had a discussion and
with regard to
transportation costs as most of you
aware
transwaste
we there's an agreement between the
councils to offset those that live
further away from the landfill site
it's 20 year old
agreement so it needed updating and
we've adjusted the formula uh to a more
fair
system which does have have a slight
impact
for our council but as i say it's a
slight impact and we also discussed a
director appointment
with regard to the joint waste committee
which
met
after the landfill committee
the main item was with regard to
contributions for waste minimisation
initiatives and due to covert
etc we have got unallocated funds at the
stage
we've agreed that we will carry
these unallocated funds over
it's important to note that the funds
are actually held by the individual
councils there was a bit of a
misunderstanding amongst some of the
councils thinking that the the joint
landfill sorry the the joint committee
had a pocket of money um
it doesn't um that the money is held by
councils and used from the councils as
necessary so
now that's all from me and i'll go back
to my main agenda
and we go on to
transport there gordon could we ask you
a question please well yeah
yeah um i've got weird concerns about
our contractors um
with waste management um number one
there's been a lot of black rubbish bags
couldn't get picked up i understood
we made them put on brand new trucks and
that picked up the bins in the black
bags at the same time
um
why why were they just going around
picking up the bins and leaving the
black bags on the side of the road when
their trucks have been specially
designed or for picking up both at the
same time
um that's that's one question the second
question as regards the transfer station
when they were going to
stop the green waste and i got several
different reasons
one was a short of hop truck drivers
and then
yourself at the community bought a load
of um drivers for the green waste they
they didn't have enough loader drivers
particularly when it's the same loader
driver that pushes the
stuff into the pit as well as the green
oasis they've only got the one loader
operating it's the same guy that does
both
and my concerns also was
when the commercial guys bring the green
waste they just said we'll dump it back
into the um into the normal rubbish bin
which
is going to require the same amount of
level of service from the operators here
with the loader and the hook truck so to
me
something's not quite clicking there i
don't know whether you could answer that
one or i think jared's got his hand up
there well i see jared and i certainly
want to make some comments because
people seem to forget that we're
going through a bloody pandemic at the
moment and it's hitting everybody but
any way i'll pass over to jared
um yeah i think it's probably more
appropriate for me to respond on
operational matters
such as these
so um
in terms of the issue
where there was a day where the black
bags were not all picked up
um early in the day the operator picking
up the bags was injured picking up the
bags um and
to
that was the
uh you know effectively the given uh the
constraints there are um and as i've
mentioned earlier in this meeting um
some of our contractors are stretched
including our waste management
contractors um
they
uh didn't have the capacity to backfill
and uh enough to be able to get the bags
that day
um as well as the bins so they picked up
the bins
in terms of the second question look
there may have been a misunderstanding
in terms of the terminology it was the
hook trucks
that are off-site so it wasn't a
capacity constraint on the actual site
um there was the ability to
use that have specialized drivers um to
operate those trucks to be able to
transport it off
site so
and we we um
we had a uh
that several day period where we um
weren't able to provide that service to
the green waste operators look i'm happy
um
if you want to further discuss that to
fill you in more on that councillor
williams
all done
transport mayor gordon
thank you mr chair i've just uh
been seeking a meeting with nzta over a
couple of issues one is the speed limit
and oxford there's been some new changes
uh approved by kev that which
may make it easy for us to
to achieve a 40k speed limit
in the township of oxford
along the lines of where the community
aspirations are so we are seeking a
meeting coming up the next week or so
with the ncta to discuss that further
and that may mean that we bring our
report back
um to secret well both the board's view
and the council's uh view on that
it's
previously
was going to require a speed um
threshold to be introduced
but my understanding is kevin has now
made a decision which will make it a
little easier it's unfortunate nzta
provided us some consistent advice here
from two different areas now staff had
had rightly relied on that um
but now they may work with this change
as i understand that may make that uh
decision a little easier and we won't
have to look at that investment before
500 000 to achieve that so we're in the
process of getting that clarified at the
moment
uh and as well um
on the agenda of conversation with nctas
the audience safety improvements
uh that's been three years uh since that
project was
um
identified
and we have been raising it all the time
and my patience is running out in the
sense of
i want to know that there's a commitment
financially to do that job
and that work and what the program is
and until i get that um
i don't want the letter to come back to
council until we've got a firm
commitment from ncta in that direction
so just letting you know uh two
reasonably reasonable issues that we
of the wooden bypass would love to see
a commitment there but we've got to be
realistic about that
[Music]
but the safety improvements is something
that's been identified for some time and
we've raised it with
um both the ministers or the previous
minister the current minister
chief executive in every forum we can
and we even brought the ncta officials
down here last year so
i really want to see some answers now
and a commitment to to that
because it's a matter that's raised and
it is important to us to see address
particularly with the growth now from
woody and pegasus
ravenswood and those connections there
so
i'll come back to you with uh where we
get to with that within the next uh
coming week we'll be meeting with nzta
to have that conversation
there's many transport issues going on
apart from that and we've got our
submission to environment category
tomorrow where um there's a number of
points there around history transport
and other things that we've agreed as
colleagues but
it's my update thank you thank you
council reuben you got a quick question
uh just a question of the mayor um if
you're advocating a 40k speed limit on
the study highway in oxford would you
consider doing the same for wood end
i'm not advocating this is what the
community uh had asked for and we're
coming we are because it'll be subject
to report i'm not advocating a 40k speed
limit and would end i don't know whether
um
whether the numbers would justify that
against the redmond but it's a matter
that joanne and the team
will would need to consider um and
something we need to discuss for the
board but that's it's a state highway so
it's not
slightly different with oxford because
it's not a state highway through the uts
and it's a road that we have control
over so
uh and that seats so i think that's the
difference um is i see if joey may wish
to provide further clarity there
going
i was just going to add that point dan
it's actually through oxford is not a
state highway it used to be
an old state highway but it was um
been handed back to council a number of
years ago
rightio
so that's the portfolio updates
council award
just a quick question
is there any chance of of trying to um
promote an underpass at the pegasus
um ravenswood area it is just virtually
impossible at the roundabout to to where
uh pedestrian or cycle um through that
busy um roundabout it's very very
dangerous
that that's part of the conversation and
we need a commitment
to the safety improvements whether it's
an underpass or another
uh form of another solution as part of
the consideration that we've been
advocating i know the communities
desire strongly for there to be an
underpass so it's a safer connection but
to matter we we need well first you need
a commitment to the safety improvements
and then we can see where that gets to
that would be a considerable cost um so
we definitely need to know what the
fiscal sum is and and and this and where
they are sitting at uh in that we've had
we have had meetings on site and we've
explained and showed
officials uh how that looks and the sort
of pressures that there are so we'll see
where that gets to but we need a
commitment from them financially first
before we start working out with
solutions but one of them certainly is
an underpass has certainly been
discussed
thank you dan that's really good
thanks for that
uh so let's finish your portfolio
updates i've got no questions
understanding orders i've got no urgent
general business
so i will move from the chair
that we go into
public excluded
[Music]
you